a middle-aged man and woman sit on a
couch filling out paperwork
title text the nih common data element
cde repository
split screen with couple on right and
nih cd repository website on left
half screen of couple changes to a nurse
in a mask and goggles taking someone's
temperature
transition to a backdrop of a
computerized world map
on the left appears video of a woman on
her laptop on the right is video of an
electronic medical questionnaire
transition to a split screen of a blue
globe with luminous connecting lines on
the left and data flowing through a city
at night on the right health data
standards enable computer systems or
software to exchange and make use of
information
transition to a split screen on the left
a woman in nursing scrubs wearing a
stethoscope reviews paperwork on the
right the hands of someone wearing a lab
coat filling out a medical form common
data elements cdes are a type of data
standard
transition to video moving through cells
dipped to white and now the video is
moving through various forms of data
enabling researchers to use data across
studies transition to a woman in a lab
coat wearing a stethoscope
standing behind a transparent screen
with medical data displayed on the
screen she presses a button on the
screen cds increase statistical power
impact research outcomes and accelerate
discovery transition to the nih cd
repository website the word fatigue is
typed into the search bar the cursor
moves to the search button and clicks
links to three fatigue-related medical
forms appear the cursor moves to one
form and selects it
transition to part of the world at night
city lights dot the otherwise dark
expanse
a video appears on the left of a woman
in scrubs speaking to a man in a
hospital bed a video appears on the
right close-up of a microscope and
gloved hand pulling a test tube full of
blue liquid from a tray
nlm provides access to cdes from across
nih search browse compare and export
transition to a backdrop undulating
waves of translucent data for more
information visit cde.nlm.nih.gov
transition to a tilted and rotating
wheel of data at its center is a star
with the word trust a ring around the
star has the words national library of
medicine
for more health resources nlm.nih.gov
transition to nih nlm logo serving
scientists in society
you